a lot of arts go in green yes we're
seeing I'm preparing the special issue
now on ecological art I did a story on
this when I was a young reporter at art
news back in the early 90s and people
were already planting seeds and the same
things I was just talking about of
cleaning the rivers but now they're
shows all over the world there's so much
art being done in global warming not
only the paintings of icebergs there's
somebody in Antarctica who's taping the
icebergs melting I mean there's just so
many different responses there's so many
groups collaborative artists
environmentalists science tech people
all working together on the ecology now
we're also doing another story on
whether some of the artworks that kind
of present themselves as environmental
or ecological or in fact using a lot of
resources